qui a comme projet de venir nous en dire
beaucoup plus sur ce qu'elle a glanée
pour nous dans son cartable de rentrée
pour nos enfants et je suis sûr que ça
vous intéresse et anne parce que l'on se
pose de sérieuses questions là sur la
rentrée scolaire mais elle va aider nos
enfants on va l'aider à retrouver si
vous me le permettez en vous remerciant
d'avoir été avec mon duplex depuis
chevigny anne mercier hameau alors je
suis très impatient de découvrir notre
sélection
dites moi tiphaine que se passe-t-il
pour cette rentrée alors moi au niveau
de la formation on a plutôt avancer ou
reculer l'âge c'est comme vous voulez on
est plutôt sur des six sept ans là et je
vous ai amené une méthode
d'apprentissage de la lecture la
fabuleuse méthode du professeur tagada
de christophe nicolas et guillaume
l'ansés publié par didier jeunesse alors
vous le voyez un le professeur tagada et
très sûr de lui puisque sa méthode est
fabuleuse et première leçon est bien
venté tout ce que les enfants vont
pouvoir faire seule une fois qu'ils
seront lire aller aux toilettes choisir
leur place sur le menu du restaurant et
même passer leur permis il voit très
très loin et avec ce livre découvrir les
lettres et l'assemblage pour faire des
mots est un vrai jeu un jeu d'enfant et
un jeu aussi pour les parents puisque
chaque exemple est émaillé de petites
blagues alors déjà pour vous donner le
contexte il faut savoir que le
professeur tagada vous avez vu son look
est accompagné d'un assistant un poussin
qui s'appelle 35 ans je sais pas si vous
l'avez pascal praud gaza maintenant oui
tu te balades chance aux jo deux sont
peut-être non à la baule tonnes alors
vous voyez un les références et les
blagues potaches sont pour les parents
et pour les enfants il y en a pour tous
les goûts et les fraises aussi le poste
sierre les enfants à la lecture au
plaisir au jeu des mots aux jeux de mots
aussi il est pas question de remplacer
les professeurs avec ses dessins
humoristiques et les blagues pipi caca
mais l'idée c'est que les parents et les
enfants s'amuser voit que c'est bien la
lecture c'est un plaisir parler
d'enfants vous n'avez pas comment aussi
tous les deux christophe et dominique
vous avez trois enfants
bérengère bastien et blanche pour vous
dominique et pour vous etienne qui est à
nouveau papa on vous êtes jean père
guillaume et cécile c'est ça super hop
je referme la parenthèse parle des
enfants voilà
donc ils sont particulièrement concernés
vous l'avez compris tiphaine on a besoin
de votre deuxième sélection s'il vous
plaît et quelque chose me dit que vous
avez choisi des livres qui ajoute encore
des devoirs aux enfants je me trompe et
oui un petit peu mais sûrement si vous
invitez ont des enfants et bien il ya
une question
qui est leur hantise chaque soir c'est
tu as fait tes devoirs
et ça eh bien c'est incontournable
puisque les devoirs devait être interdit
je vous le rappelle mais ce n'est pas du
tout le cas et il y à un dessinateur qui
a décidé d'en faire le sujet de sa bd
c'est dommage c'est publié chez bamboo
et là on retrouve
toutes les situations qui peuvent se
poser en plus que tom lui fait tout pour
éviter de faire ses devoirs alors il a
toujours autre chose de mieux à faire et
il ya toujours et bien des circonstances
qui l'empêchent de se plonger dans son
travail sa soeur ses parents essayent de
l'aider mais ça ne marche pas toujours
c'est vraiment une bande dessinée très
très drôle qui sent le vécu on s'amuse à
chaque page que ce soit les parents ou
les enfants et surtout à la fin il y a
un petit dossier pédagogique justement
pour aider les parents et les enfants à
savoir comment mieux faire ses devoirs à
votre avis plutôt avant ou après le
goûter moi je dirais
avant le goûter c'est comme ça je vais
dire mais tu auras le goûter cet effet
les deux voies mais je suis sûr vous
allez me dire linverse et ben ça dépend
des enfants seuls ou à plusieurs pareil
on ne sait pas trop comment retenir une
leçon à vous connaissez l'histoire du
walkman quand on s'endort là ce truc
dans les années 80 qu'on disait il en
est question aussi là dedans avec un mp3
et comme pour d'anglais maintenant j'en
avais l'instant cette bd ouais
allait rapidement parce qu'il nous reste
vraiment très peu de temps d'émission un
livre pour les cm2 et les collégiens
comme ça il y aura pas de jaloux parce
que je parlais tout à l'heure de votre
fille suzanne qui veulent entrer en
sixième donc si le collège on y va pour
faire des jaloux il ya eric aussi votre
fils qui nous écoutent oui alors c'est
la bd qui t'aide à te concentrer à mieux
organiser de géraldine bindi et mature
roda chez casterman des enfants se
demandent comment ils vont concilier les
soirs et les goûters avec les copains le
sport et puis et bien le collège et
c'est fichu de voir et bien là dedans il
y a les réponses à leurs questions alors
ça pourrait sembler être un manuel de
coaching pour grands sportifs mais pas
du tout c'est drôle ça apporte plein de
petites réponses et à la fin il y a des
petites pages comme ça pour essayer de
trouver et bien ce qui vous correspond
alors quels sont les points forts des
enfants leur semaine idéale
comment surmonter un échec vraiment je
vous le conseille parce qu'il ya le côté
bd assez amusant et puis ces petits
exercices qu'on peut faire à la maison
avec ses parents orphelins vrais livres
pour apprendre à se connaître ben génial
la sélection livre de la région et
d'ailleurs à retrouver aussi sur le net
et les réseaux sociaux merci tu es fan
c'est joli ce plan là que nous a fait
vincent là on avait des rosés vous
diriez on n'a que des fleurs aujourd'hui
c'est magnifique vous êtes merci pascal
vous êtes tous très beaux et toutes très
belles et moi sagem